now let's get to our five headlines  nancy pelosi should have been publicly  told years ago that you can't receive  communion it's kind of a bittersweet  celebration the archbishop  of san francisco is calling for speaker  nancy pelosi to be denied receiving  community because of her pro-choice  stand this is not your job dude  no uh whoopi that is  literally his job  are you stupid or something when we talk  about the children of the community  they are a children of the community  when they say that when they say  community what they mean is the  government this is totally predictable  sure you're out of line so that's beto  just using uh 19 dead children as a  stage  for a political stunt do you believe  that school district should keep a  child's involvement and gender  transition a secret from their parents i  would love to answer questions on the  budget this is yet another example of  institutional cowardice